seit dem friedensabkommen von 1998 s
daumens die institution in der
unionisten und republikaner gemeinsam
gesetze zum wohle nordirlands
verabschieden sollen nach den wahlen
anfang mai aber liegt das parlament
blockiert von der protestantischen der
op wieder einmal im tiefschlaf für
limerick dichter steven murphy ist die
sache klar die hauptschuld trägt die
regierung von boris johnson
lieber boris hab versucht dich zu
missachten wie einen älteren verwandten
der nur darauf wartet dass man ihn
öffentlich wird beachten um unüberlegt
animositäten zu verbreiten über die
weltpolitische lage und
wahlmöglichkeiten doch anders als der
betrunkene onkel der nüchtern wird und
buße tut scheint als sei es deiner
regierung einziges bestreben bedingt
durch angeborene kolonialer ambitionen
angst und hass und alle alten
traditionen aus dem grab zu holen und
heimlich zu beleben
ganz nordirland ist gelähmt von leuten
die sich weigern ihre differenzen
miteinander zu besprechen dazu führen
sie das nordirland protokoll an und
sagen was ihnen alles nicht passt wie
kleinkinder die spielzeug aus dem
kinderwagen werden sie wollen einfach
nicht an den verhandlungstisch und ihre
konflikte lösen die bereits seit
generationen existieren
begründet liegt die blockadehaltung der
unionisten in der angst vor einer
weiteren annäherung nordirlands an
irland durch den wahlsieg von schiffen
und steigende katholische geburtenraten
haben sich die machtverhältnisse weiter
verschoben
hinzu kommt die neue zollgrenze in der
irischen see zwischen großbritannien und
eben ein zugeständnis von boris johnson
an die eu dass er nun mit hilfe eines
nationalen gesetzes rückgängig machen
will womit auch die gewaltbereitschaft
protestantische extremisten weiter
befeuert werden könnte die leidtragenden
sind die anwohner der pis world viele
wurden erst nach dem good friday clement
errichtet um die verfeindeten nachbarn
voneinander zu trennen
sie schmeißen dauernd steine aufs dach
man kann zwar die polizei rufen aber die
tun nichts und die kaputten ziegel
bekommen wir auch nicht ersetzt denn
laut polizei handelt es sich ja nicht um
ausschreitungen wenn es welche wären
könnte man reklamieren aber das
angeblich kein überfall ist
direkt hinter den mauern ist der
nordirische frieden noch längst nicht
angekommen seit jahrzehnten werden die
katholischen anwohner von polizei und
behörden diskriminiert und sozial
geächtet
aber auch auf der anderen seite nehmen
frustration arbeitslosigkeit und soziale
probleme zu die wechselnden regierungen
in london sehen meist tatenlos zu
an der grenze wuchs ich auf hat familie
in süd und nord schwer fällt die
bigotterie zu ignorieren die du aus
speist mit jedem wort wenn man die
troubles als einen bürgerkrieg versteht
und nicht als akteur richter banalität
und obwohl das protokoll für dich ein
spielzeug ist dass du zu deinem vorteil
nutzt bis es sich von selbst auf frist
ist doch nur ein pflaster für eine
selbst gemachte wunde buchstabiert
vollkommenes desaster und rubin zur
absehbarer stunde
[Musik]
belfast wirtschaftsboom steht nach dem
brett auf der kippe viele bewohner haben
mit steigenden energiekosten maroder
gesundheitsversorgung und akuter
wohnungsnot zu kämpfen gesetze zugunsten
ärmerer bevölkerungsschichten liegen auf
eis immer mehr jungen nordiren auch
protestantischer herkunft zieht es daher
ins wohlhabendere irland
ein kulturzentrum im norden belfasts
aber versteht sich als brückenbauer
zwischen den konfessionen
auch diese jungen musikerinnen haben
sich dort kennengelernt
si
das risiko
[Musik]
nicht
red
das was unsere generation versucht ist
sich nicht auf die schlechten dinge der
vergangenheit zu konzentrieren für mich
ist die gemeinschaft viel wichtiger ich
denke weniger darüber nach welchen
sozialen hintergrund jemand hat oder
welcher religion er angehört
das spielt für mich keine rolle und die
leute machen sich darüber keine sorgen
mehr viel interessanter ist es doch alle
möglichen unterschiedlichen leute zu
treffen
ein presbyterianischen geistlicher und
ein katholischer kulturmanager haben
diese ehemaligen ort belfaster kirche in
einen ort kultureller begegnung und eine
anlaufstation für sozial schwache
verwandelt für beide konfessionen
[Musik]
versöhnung geschieht in dem moment wenn
menschen etwas über einander erfahren
und lernen tolerant zu sein die tatsache
dass sie verschiedene ansichten soziale
hintergründe kulturen oder religionen
haben heißt noch lange nicht dass man
aufeinander einprügeln muss wir stellen
dafür die plattform zur verfügung die
leute können hier herkommen voneinander
lernen und so ihre negativität und
gegenseitiges misstrauen überwinden
der frieden in nordirland bleibt fragil
vor zwei tagen holten die unionisten
instrument ihre verschobene parade zum
100 jährigen jubiläum des nordirischen
parlaments nach um gestern zum zweiten
mal per abstimmung die bildung einer
einheitsregierung mit der katholischen
sinn fein zu verweigern